[Music]
and to bliss news oh that's interesting
toothless tipless ooh what else would
that someone like a dragon okay it's
perfect
to be submitted by get to the choppa I
feel like I should have said I would
like to it you have to just do the job
bah
no no get to the chopper into the Jaffa
this celebrity says she lost her front
teeth from being too stressed out well
how can you do that dude that sounds
like a great Japanese company slogan
work to your teeth fall out
damn hmm that's so depressing though
that would both tell me that they're
stressed out I want your [ __ ] [ __ ]
you start your teeth how did you sold
stress dollars you just started pulling
on a page instead of pulling on her hair
[ __ ] that make sense yeah cuz I can feel
like uh no no my teeth hurt when I work
out yeah I wish I could get so stressed
that my belly falls out expect only
convenience
well I don't have two more people on
another kind of wave don't get some
stress yeah no I gave with it but you
know what I eat Deanie really skinny
guys with a six-pack is like a really
really big girl with big boobs it's the
same it doesn't count
oh it's a given yeah
yes it's not fair that's what I'm saying
yes I guess which celebrity lost her oh
my god it'll be a Lohan Miley Cyrus I'm
gonna have to close I'll give you some
clues okay doctor so like narrowing okay
okay uh so this I would give a righteous
but you know there's an actress okay
American okay uh was mainly like her
height was in the I'd say 90 or tangible
a height of the peak of her career Hall
CD famous or movie fame yes movie movie
apartment um mushy I mean Oh Nicole
Kidman okay she was married to uh uh or
not Olsen twins no someone really
that's the last clip astronomical
shipping oh no the other one na jale oh
no no no laughter good but when I shave
your head GI Jane whatever your name is
very war there you go oh that's a she
wasn't mad yes it is anymore no way
Devon well holy crap you said you're
gonna get it right you actually did I
got it oh you just knew the action oh my
god he said the goal of the ball head
he's a dead woman I literally said the
movie though yeah game thank you yeah
but that's not the actress you know it
is action if you're playing jeopardy you
can't write something else that's not
the cab yeah you're so red Burmese rule
if you're playing jeopardy for you as
you say we gotta keep the we wasn't
written on the world go because he said
we so he would say let's both with
issues at my [ __ ] elbow [ __ ] anyways
thank you party you'll be disqualified
you both got her okay here we go anymore
yeah my you got it shut up anymore do
striptease [ __ ] yeah yeah
so here's Demi Moore and Jimmy Fallon's
show and she was telling him how stress
led to 102 falling out 1 1 yep so it has
nothing to do with cocaine oh holy [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] up right there you look
like a jack-o'-lantern
yeah so shoot her she look like she get
to look like trailer park trash I heard
she's a baby wants to go puke done to a
face yeah should add eight more [ __ ]
extra have you guys seen girl you're
gonna [ __ ] up in front of lots of people
Russell stress nabela Vanessa yeah Casey
doesn't have a to do that because they
never grew he has a Millington pictures
of not and can implement um no I think
I've seen the I guess their means of
when people edit out the celebrity that
he they look [ __ ] off like a smile is
hope imported calendar we would look
like the caller she will do it all
different so different there from other
picture oh yeah no there's no me I mean
right here she she not looks like oh
yeah
oh my gosh she looks hot there or she
wasn't ghost right yeah yeah my machine
are like 85 everyone I don't know I'm a
dog and I know he's my I broke you can't
even Thomas e85 like really cheese like
late know the movie oh well basically
actually naked though oh my god she was
her legs was her boobs were perfect when
her boobs were perfect first and then
came Angelina Jolie and replaced those
boobs and I'm like Dan those blues
they're perfect what she's making for by
the way Connor 54 years old amateurs of
the Aston Kutcher it that's the countess
before we roll the one that yeah I
shoulda thought how come she looks so
jacked up another picture I should
really do you know dude and she's not
wearing makeup and she is like in her
special day like 30 pounds I feel like
girls
I got Vangelis great yeah yeah you know
we didn't I know I know but God is most
trusted literally full yeah so that's
the thing so they're saying that this is
swallow her toothbrush you escaped the
suspect entered the food is on across
the moment it fell out shooting going to
details there it was just the fact that
she said this well he'll look she said
good go I shared my off my front teeth
I'd love to say I was skateboarding or
something really
cool but but I think it's something
that's important to share because it's
literally probably after heart disease
one of the biggest killers in America
which is stress stress sheared off my
front teeth wow man I didn't even say it
like it just kind of fell no a dude
she's just like so she did before
Christopher
several years ago she did go on Ellen
DeGeneres's show and bought Bruce Willis
stress drop and she said that some of
her teeth had fallen out due to her
clenching them so hard oh she does have
like issues with her like grinding she
love me
watch clenched so Harley what are the
dead kids don't do drugs don't distress
unless was ecstasy it's kind of fun
unless she's [ __ ] I don't know that
she's cold on time I get that when I
would drink a lot of caffeine I don't
drink it anymore but when I would
drinking a lot I would I would wish yeah
like it would get sore and it wasn't
until I felt helps or was it I'm like oh
[ __ ] I need to relax I have to like
purposely over my mouth and just keep it
over again like what the [ __ ] is
happening a lot I might have liked it oh
I do that fake sound mattress oh really
you have all the news hello
okay so when I was younger um I realized
I had grinded down my my canine
completely like they're like splat teeth
battling with your friends yeah and then
I also I woke up one morning after like
a whole night of grinding my teeth and I
saw the little piece of my tooth are you
within my mouth and I was like why do I
like piece of bone in there but then
took out my sure we should play - oh my
god actually been like grinding right
people I chipped the back of my molar on
the salted pork chop
Oh sometimes they have a bone they
[ __ ] tell me and I bit into it I
cracked the back of my molar and I also
found out it's because I didn't I never
drink soda growing up I don't lean like
when I had a burgers my parents never
had it in the house
and then I started drinking soda when I
came here a lot of diet soda and I was
actually [ __ ] the Nano my teeth on
Keith were weak so that's why if you
know this I don't get a lot of soda
we're going to you because we know
mechanics used to tell me that back in
the day when I have to watch the gray
sock they see is coca-cola oh it's a
strips grease like crazy yeah
that's how strong it is right you order
it all the last because we eat so much
greasy food no wait oh yeah yeah why not
just lemon water or just not so much
agree no cuz when you drink the coke
it's just where the fat so your by does
absorb it yeah she cannot just expect
you know listen to that that's not true
it's clearly not true look at me because
that does not work at all what I don't
know how you don't get diet soda coming
from him you know you got to get Mexican
Coke oh do believe this guy the meathead
oh yeah Gainesville doesn't exist
James well you just discovered
Gainesville is real yeah
what there's a [ __ ] fly in here yeah
it's pissing me the [ __ ] off I just
touched it with juicy fly I know I heard
your and I like what the [ __ ] but I
didn't want to interrupt the tape is
your mom all living life do you care
about flies I do care about fun really
yeah what about flies
I [ __ ] hate mosquitoes I kill those
but flies I try not to kill them I just
try to shoosh them out hell they didn't
know I can't wait till that [ __ ]
wait on a [ __ ] windowsill dude I'm
not the [ __ ] cop real quick you know
it's my favorite thing to do to flies I
already know what it's all have a pellet
gun I let you talk like this and go like
that right and then it's so strong a
blast blast the pellets out at 1,300
feet per second when you go up to a fly
with nothing in it just air like maybe
like six inches away when you pull the
Pelican the fly just immediately gets
splattered against the window goes Zeus
fly off in the lakes flower I've only
had everything just smeared from the air
that's how you're gonna like Sun it this
would be nice like really yeah and I'm
Park it obliterates it so you don't have
to worry about the fly there's no
guessing game in it either
yeah that means if you're within six
inches it's going to get destroyed by
death and the creations are so dangerous
fine yes hahaha
that's not typed in I [ __ ] in hate
flies dude I can't wait to one of those
[ __ ] coming I hate mosquitoes
more than flies me too I hate all of
those fools mosquitoes fly everybody all
you [ __ ]
wouldn't walk never do you be people
they've been doing really heavy [ __ ]
I think they could tell I'm not killing
them so they're like oh we're gonna
leave in Maryland oh shoot I love bugs
they sing you multiple times and they
can do it's not like it's not a thing as
they bite so me look at the flowers you
just wait till you come on this Despero
my literate your ass yeah and I'm a
gloss on sunlight cuz if you gotta watch
that under my balcony on the top and I
got the wasp get home I'll [ __ ] douse
those [ __ ] do it just like that
now we know it's an get David for his
birthday a bunch of flies once you're
financed [ __ ] yeah no don't get no
hey nothing you can kill uh no I don't
enjoy the fact that they're there I
would rather not do it but if I have if
they come to my area just [ __ ] with
the wrong person I'm saying they're
disrespecting you that's why yeah it's
good warned maybe more
have you ever flex on a mosquito before
where's that me I'd be like literally
crush them at all in here don't bite you
and it's so the usual thing is to smack
them and kill them but then I might also
you want blow how much [ __ ]
blood do you want good you just [ __ ]
squeeze in the mosquito I think it's too
much
yes you it does explode but if
force-feed them too much they flies away
Oh too much like that's right [ __ ] uses
underline I did you can't [ __ ] move
now faster no because I stopped this
feminizing have a tummyache he's gonna
go over to have diarrhea blood area you
showed him you showed him that's what I
thought I know sorry you flex on his ass
for sure hey you guys want to stock any
of us we'll go ahead down to the
description box below and you can follow
us on Instagram and all kinds of stuff
for more videos
[Music]